The cause of all The Catastrophes we are seeing Today Is
Overpopulation We are proud to unveil the only practical Remedy to Humanity's Greatest problem are you Ready doctor
yes i'm Ready
Wow that is wild Isn't it it's Just Wild
That's dave dave Johnson Everybody and Carol he never struck me as the Kind of guy Who'd Go get small
downsizing Takes the pressure right off Plus you'Re Really Making a difference You Mean All That Crap about Saving the planet Yeah
downsizing is about Saving Yourself We Live Like Kings Got Best Houses best restaurants cheesecake Factory Got Three of them
In leisure laying Your
$52,000 translates to
12.5 million Dollars to live on but life
wow do you understand that You will undergo the permanent and irreversible medical procedure Commonly Known as
downsizing and That Your Bodies Will Be approximately point zero three six four Percent of Their Current Mass and volume
Nervous
Little
Missy on the other side
The Smart World is Filled with Things to see
Sometimes You think we're in the normal world and something happens oh?
My God
You Realize we're not